hey what's up my name's Samuel Leeds and
this is property investors Q&A Sunday
having a decision on their answer some
questions from last week if you have
questions this week then comment them
below all of your niggling annoying
property questions there is no question
that can beat you stupid or to done
anything about property investing do you
want to know comment below I'll do my
best to answer next week so you've got a
comment below ask a question then
subscribe turn the notification bell on
and boom you'll get ting next week and I
might be answering your questions but
let's see what we've got this week so
Special K says what's your predictions
for the housing market over the next 12
months great question I think it depends
on where you are you know if you watch
London there's always a rippling effect
however if you ask me what's going to
happen over the next 12 months depending
on where like for instance Birmingham
property prices right now are absolutely
soaring same as Manchester soaring
London property prices are static in
fact they were even dipping a little bit
so why is that well that's because in
London from 2011 to 2016 those five
years property price has doubled in some
parts of London literally doubled over
five years so of course after a massive
expansion is going to come a recession
so if you want to predict what's going
to happen in an area look what the last
five or seven years did and then
probably the next five or seven years
we'll do the exact opposite so Liverpool
Liverpool property prices are not
soaring in Liverpool but they just
beginning to pick up a little bit so
it's a difficult question to answer
just to say profits at the housing
market because the a recession can
happen in just one city and another city
so you've got to find an area where by
it's like okay this area's bombed out or
this area has just gone down now it's
going to go up and then for capital
appreciation that's what I would say so
that's my general advice hope that helps
George Fontbonne says is it realistic
that you can achieve 20% return on
investment and I'd buy to let that is
above sixty five thousand pounds yes
George it is realistic 20 percent is
kind of like the target as like if you
can hit 20 percent or above then then
you're doing really well
and I think with a property over 65,000
pounds
I mean 65 grand is not a lot for a house
so I mean even if you even if you rent
it out by the room you know if usually
if you turn it into a hey CH mo you
could very realistically get above 20%
can you do a lease option plant in
places like London yes you can do lease
options in London at least options when
you buy a house now and you agree to pay
for it later yeah you can do it you can
do a lease option anywhere the only
place you can't do a lease option in the
UK as far as I'm aware is Scotland you
can do a delayed sale but the rules are
different I don't know if your question
is can you do it legally or is it all
their properties that would work for
this strategy can you yet all their
properties that would work for the
strategy yes but because there's been
such a massive expansion in London over
the last over the last sort of like 5 5
8 years since after we recovered from
the recession in 2008 when crazy the
properties in London there's not much
negative equity so everyone that's
selling that's got equity in their
property their proper that they're like
oh wow look at how much the house has
gone up for sale so often when they're
selling the house they wanted to get the
money now so it might be more difficult
to find someone that would be up willing
to sell the house on a lease option
agreement but hey it's definitely
possible ok Danny heap are there any
crash courses in the new year up north
Danny I have a good news for you man we
are running a property investors crash
course in January in Manchester
Manchester in January I don't know why
we went to Manchester everyone always
says please go to Manchester go to
Manchester and to be honest it kind of
ticks me off when people say that
because I just think just travel man
like if you're prepared to do whatever
it takes if you're an unstoppable person
which by the way you've got to be in
order to succeed in property and in
business just generally speaking you've
got to be prepared to just jump jump in
the car get a taxi for a few hours but
we're coming to Manchester so have fun
bullet on because we might not come to
Manchester again so that's in January
I'll leave a link for you Danny and
anyone else that wants to come to
Manchester property investors crash
course I'll leave a link below ok
jazmyne says overseas buying what
overseas buyers investing HMOs
profitable yeah it could be real
profitable if you're overseas you can
make some difference you can still you
know you
move money around in fact you can even
make money on the currency if you play
your cards right so yeah hundred percent
property hunters are you renting the
flat seam ribs foot or selling them
great question I think I'm gonna sell
some and keep some so it just depends on
I'm definitely gonna put my money back
out I'm definitely gonna sell some and
then whether I refinance others or sell
still to be decided but I'll definitely
keep you posted I definitely he posted
it on YouTube last question is Sam
Walley where do you see yourself in five
and ten years time still property
investing or retired Sam I'll never
retire I'll never retire if I was going
to retire I'd have already retired so no
man I'm still gonna be buying houses I'm
still gonna be property investing I'm
still gonna be pushing myself pushing
the boundaries I'm very very confident
in property investing in the UK over the
next 50 years I think it's very safe
we're on a small island with limited
housing a massive shortage of housing
and an overpopulation of people and
ultimately if you buy property and own
land then then you're going to be the
you're gonna be the person that can call
the shots and financially you're going
to win so that's what I'm really
passionate about investing in property I
don't know what your thoughts are
comment below I want to see all the
comments I want to see you comments I
want to see your questions put them in
the box also please don't forget to
smash that like button if you haven't
subscribed to the channel I'm gonna have
to hunt you down and find you and make
you subscribe even if I'm logging in
press the button myself please do
subscribe and put a little subscribe
buttom right here see if you haven't
subscribed now's your chance man it's
right here push that button I'll see you
next time
[Music]